[music]
>> Now we go to the next part.
That is
revision of the
revision of
How many?
25? I thought it was 114.
25 or 114?
25, raise your hand.
Who says 25?
Who says 114, raise your hand?
Okay.
That means I'm lying.
I'm lying?
Sorry.
Homework for?
No, no, I'm sorry. Yesterday's homework
for today was 25. Two weeks before's
homework was 114.
I say 114, you're saying 25. People will
think I'm lying. Right?
Right or wrong? How can both be right?
Both are right. Yes. Yesterday's
homework is 25, but 2 weeks back
homework is 114. So, should we take 2
weeks before homework or yesterday's
homework?
Huh?
Yesterday. Okay, I agree.
I prefer See, first you finish the
backlog, then comes.
Okay.
You want 25 only?
Okay. Who knows names of 25 surahs with
meaning very well, raise your hand.
Masha Allah.
All except two. Who doesn't know very
well, raise your hand.
Three.
Brother Imran, you didn't raise your
hand for knows very well, neither
See, I do counter-checking. Masha Allah,
I have good good memory, yeah?
See, this is again
One is being smart, one is extra smart.
Sometimes it's possible.
But when I'm saying who has done the
homework very well, knows very well,
raise your hand. Who hasn't done well?
He didn't raise it even for knowing
well, even didn't raise it for not
knowing very well. Is it possible?
Is it possible, brother Imran?
You were right one time and you were
wrong the other time. Yes or no? Give
him the microphone.
If certain time you cannot raise both
the times because you don't know.
You did not raise your hand when I said
who knows the 25 surah name very well,
you didn't raise your hand. Correct?
When I said who doesn't know, raise your
hand.
Two three people raised. You didn't
raise. Why?
If you cross-question me, I might not be
able to answer. So, I was So, then you
don't know very well. So, raise your
hand you don't know. If you think you
will not be able to answer, should you
raise your hand when you know or when
you don't know very well? The word was
very well.
So, were you right or were you wrong in
not raising both the times?
Wrong.
Will you do it again? No.
Inshallah. Allah. Inshallah. Inshallah.
See, therefore I told you
to be smart is good.
To be extra smart is not good.
I ask questions specifically.
If it's some other person, you can get
away with it. I'm doing eye to eye
contact. I'm observing people. Once in a
while, you may skip it.
Please, I'm repeating.
Anyone who's acting extra smart now will
be exposed in the next couple of days.
And that reminds me. You know, I made a
statement before I ended the last
session that two or three people are
extra smart.
Please improve. And I was stunned and I
went away.
You know,
two participants came to my room.
Brother Zakir, I said, "What happened?"
Brother Zakir,
"Have I done something wrong?" I said,
"No." "No, am I the person that you're
angry with?" I said, "No."
Alhamdulillah. Another person comes. He
said, "What happened?" "Why are you
coming to my room?" "No, no, am I the
person
I said, "No."
Alhamdulillah.
Now, was it right for these two people
to come and disturb me in my room?
Was it right or wrong? Who says it's
right, raise your hand.
Very good. One person.
If you know,
you know, Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam,
he told the names
of 14 munafiqeen
to a Sahaba.
But told him not to tell anyone.
When the news spread that Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said that
amongst the people around him, there are
14 munafiqeen,
he told to one Sahaba, but told him not
to tell anyone. Hazrat Umar Radiyallahu
Anhu,
who the prophet called him as the second
best Muslim in the world after the
Ambiya.
The prophet said, Hazrat Abu Bakr, may
Allah be pleased with him, if he's put
on one side and the full Ummah,
excluding the Ambiya, Hazrat Abu Bakr,
his taqwa and iman would be heavier than
the full Ummah put together. Then a
second Hadith, that put Hazrat Umar on
one side, may Allah be pleased with him,
and the full Ummah, leaving aside the
Ambiya and Hazrat Abu Bakr,
he alone will be heavier.
That means they are the two stalwart,
number one, number two, the prophet gave
indication.
Hadrat Umar went to that Sahaba, may
Allah be pleased with him, and asked him
that what are the say I cannot tell you
THE NAMES. AM I ONE OF THEM? HE SAID,
"NO." And he said, "Alhamdulillah."
Now, these two people who came to my
room
Imagine
in a wildest dream who can think that
Hadrat Umar, may Allah be pleased with
him, can be considered nothing? No one
would think.
The Iman was so strong, but they were so
AFRAID THAT WHAT IF BY CHANCE, THOUGH
THE chance is 0.00001%, where will it
come we don't know.
The Iman is so strong that I don't want
even that
0.001%.
He went and verified, "Am I that
munafiq?"
And may Allah reward these two
participants.
And may Allah grant them Jannah,
inshallah.
Most of them were rooting here, "How can
I be that person?
You know, I'm a guy I've come from so
far.
I'm a guy I've come from so and so
country. I've sacrificed so much. Can I
be that person? No.
We learn from the Seerah of the prophet
and the life of the Sahabas.
What is Islam?
I was happy.
Unfortunately, none of those two and
three who actually are there
came to me. I didn't expect them to
come.
Because
if they had that much of knowledge of
the Deen, they wouldn't have done it in
the first place.
You understand?
Now, I'm educating you about the Deen.
The eye lecture is one thing, public
speaking.
You have better public speakers than we
have alhamdulillah, hundreds and
thousands of them.
Implementing it is important.
I'm repeating it.
Please
don't try to be extra smart. Being smart
is good.
I'm repeating it lightly. Every time I
repeat,
I'll get more tough.
I'm asking you a question, both are
contradicting, and you don't raise your
hand both the times,
you're wasting my time to remind you.
Is it clear for everyone?
Yes, brother Imran. Is it clear?
Please, don't waste.
You have to pay attention.
You can't say I was dreaming. If you're
dreaming, then
out.
You can't afford to dream here.
Correct?
And slowly, slowly,
it will be exposed.
It's good.
Okay, fine. If you're not sure, raise it
at least one time.
If you're not sure, then neither in the
portion which I'm not sure. That's us.
So, three raised their hand,
brother saying, brother Vinod, and
brother Atiq.
Yes, brother. Why didn't you
do the lesser homework properly?
Difficult?
My [snorts] memory is very bad.
>> [laughter]
>> My memory is bad in in the
memorizing.
>> Memory is bad?
25 words you cannot remember? 25 25 50
words?
50 words in 2 weeks is difficult?
I'll try my best again.
Is it possible or not possible? Am I
asking you something impossible?
No, it's not impossible, inshallah.
Inshallah.
How many do you know very well?
Did you try or did you not try?
I tried. You tried, masha Allah. How
many hours did you spend on it?
How many hours did you try?
There's a limit. Okay, I tried for 10
hours, and I could not remember. It's
okay, alhamdulillah. You tried. How many
hours did you spend?
Few hours. How many? Few hours. No, few
is vague. I want specific. Few can be
two, can be three, can be 10.
How many hours did you spend trying to
memorize 25 surahs? I admit that
>> 25 surahs. How many? I admit that I
didn't put enough time. How many? Tell
us frankly, brother. Actually, how many
hours did you put to try to memorize the
25 surah names with meanings?
Two or three.
>> Be frank. Two or three, maybe.
Two or three minutes or hours?
Minutes or hours?
Two or three minutes you spend or two or
three hours you spend? How many hours
did you try to memorize 25 surahs?
Think again, huh? Be truthful Full in
answer.
Allah says in the Quran, in Surah Nisa,
chapter number four, verse number 135.
Ya ayyuhallazina amanu, oh you believe,
stand up for justice as witness to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, even if it be
against your own self.
Against your parents.
Against your relatives. Against the rich
or poor. Allah protects all.
So, when you're giving an answer
truthfully, it may go against you also,
no problem.
How many hours did you put in?
How many hours did you spend?
One or two. One or two?
Brothers, somebody give him a
microphone.
You don't have to repeat the answer. How
many hours did you actually put in to
try to memorize? Or maybe okay, five
minutes I tried, I could not get it, I
gave up. How many hours?
Since last night.
Since last night? Since last night means
the last 12 hours you're memorizing?
Since last night is 100% wrong. Why?
Because from morning you are here, and
since morning till now, in front of me,
that means while I was speaking, you're
memorizing? No. So, answer is right or
wrong? Wrong. Wrong.
Since last night means whether your
night starts at 12:00 or 10:00 or 1:00.
Since last night means from that 12:00
till now, it's a wrong answer. I know
English.
I may not be better than you in English,
I don't know, but my English is good,
masha Allah.
Since last night means since last night
till now. Correct?
Specific answers when I ask how many
hours, it should be numbers.
It may be approximate, half an hour, 1
hour.
Quarter hour.
How many hours did you actually That
means you didn't sleep only since last
night? No.
I sleep. I asked them how many hours you
slept. All of them said minimum 4 hours,
5 hours, 6 hours. So, either you're
lying then or you're lying now.
See, this is very important when a guy
gives a word. His book should be an open
book. Never lie.
Never try and give a vague answer, also.
Because you may think Zakir Naik's
memory is not good.
Fine, it's not good, but Allah says it's
with me.
When I ask questions,
it goes in my data bank.
I retrieve it when required, otherwise
it goes out.
>> [music]
[music]
[chanting]
>> Allah.